hi everyone I hope you're all doing very
well today we're going to work on side
steps front steps and back steps those
are the basic directions that we use
when we walk run without stumble now the
first time you will be that sometimes
you need to use big steps and sometimes
you need to use small steps and the
technique for each one is different
so this is something we are going to
concentrate our on today how your
technique changes when you need to
change the size of your steps so in this
class we will first do our warm-up then
we are going to work on our side step
first we will do it small and then we
will do it B and we will see the
different techniques for H then we are
going to work on front and back steps
with change of weight each time with a
different day we will do it small under
big with the different techniques and
then again we are going to use small
sequences where we are going to combine
side and front and back and each
exercise we will do it slowly with a
slow tempo and then we will do a faster
version so to have more feeling of real
advance okay so let's start with the
warmup okay one more today's going to be
a bit different because balance is such
an important quality to have when we
understand go today we are going to do
the same exercises that we do on the
previous warm-ups but we are going to do
them on one day okay each exercise we
will do it first on one leg and then on
the other day
some exercises are not possible to do on
one leg or very difficult so we will
find variations for those the first
exercise used to be shoulder rotations
like this so we will do a shoulder
rotations first on the left
and then on the right there okay so put
your weight on the left raised a little
bit the right foot and then let's do a
slow shoulder rotations one two remember
not to use the elbows three four five
six seven and eight
now switch your weight to the right foot
and eight more one two three four five
six seven eight
now the next exercises was army circles
like this will fit together so we will
do the same put your weight on the left
foot and let's do it slow arm circles
one two
remember to stretch the elbows three
keep the shoulders down four five six
seven
now sweets away to the right foot let's
go anymore
one two three four five keep your head
straight six seven one eight okay
the next exercise was stretch the side
of your torso like this yeah
first one side then the other side so
when we do this on one leg is not
possible to go that far to the side
because it's difficult but we can go a
little bit at least
okay so put your weight on the left foot
raise the right arm and then try to go a
little bit to the side one hold it and
then go back to the vertical and drop
down now change the way to the right
foot raise the left arm until it's
vertical try to move it to the side one
and then again to the vertical drop down
switch the weight raise stress decide to
drop down switch the weight with the arm
go to the side two
sweets the weight raised on go to the
side three hold it go up sweets the
weight break sorry go to the side three
hold it on up now there are sweets the
way to the left
raise the right arm go to the side for
hold it up sweets the weight if they are
going to go to the sign for up let's do
one more time switch the weight to the
left foot raise the right arm go to the
side five then drop down switch the
weight to the right foot lift the left
arm okay now the next exercise was
opening the legs bending the knees and
making a circle with the arms and rotate
the middle like this so let's try to do
it on one leg put your weight on the
left leg and for balance I recommend to
bend the knee yeah very nice now make a
circle with the arms in front of you and
let's try to do sixteen rotations of the
middle okay one two three four five six
seven eight one two three four five
six and seven and eight
now sweets the way to the right leg bend
the knee make a circle with ours in
front of you keep them low don't raise
them keep them low and this is sixteen
more one two three four five six seven
eight one two three four five six seven
eight okay
the next exercise was with the legs to
open and stretch hands behind hip lower
the back until it was parallel to the
floor and then continuing down and
bounce three times and then go up now if
we try to do this on one day we can only
do a short version of these exercise I'm
going to show you on the profile first
you put your weight on the left foot
okay raise the right foot and bend the
standing leg which makes the exercise a
little bit easier now put your hands
behind your head okay now when you go
forward try to keep your back straight
and the free leg will go back to
compensate for the weight that is going
forward
okay so that you staying matters not too
much just a little bit okay and then try
to bend your back almost until you're
parallel with the floor that's enough
okay and then you
so let's try hands behind head raise
their right foot and then one go down
bend the knee and go up we try to at
least eight times okay two down three
down four down five down what
sinem down
okay good now let's move to the other
side so put your weight on the right
foot lift the left a little bit put your
hands behind your back open your chest
lift your ribs
you know I'm then let's go
bend the knee one and what - and knee
go down go up three go up
four five six seven eight down hold it
okay good
the next exercise was with the legs open
and stretch we grab our hips and within
circles with the hips now this is not
possible on one leg because your center
of gravity is going all over the place
yeah so you can't do this but if you do
it on one leg on me at least you can go
back and forward with the hip okay so
let's try to do exactly that
put your weight on the left foot raise
the right foot and try the doing the
whole exercise your free leg doesn't
open and it stays together with the
standing leg okay now grab your hips and
stretch your standing leg completely
okay now let's try to go forward with a
hip and back with a hip yeah so back and
forward back and forth okay this is with
eight times on the left back one two
keep the standing leg stretch three four
five six seven eight
okay very good
now change the way to the right lift the
leg put it together with the standing
leg stretch your standing leg and let's
do eight more go back one two three four
five six
the last 1/8
okay now the last exercise was with feet
together we would balance three times
with knees bent then we will stretch the
legs and then we would go up on the toes
and hold it for three seconds you can
still do this on one leg it's a little
bit harder especially when you go up so
we won't hold it that long
but let's try anyway to do it so put
your weight on the left foot right leg
together with your standing foot and now
let's bounce on our standing knee three
times one two three then stretch the leg
then move your way to the forward part
of your foot and raise the heel
underneath hold it as long as you can if
you can't hold a three seconds that's
great and then down okay and then we
will switch the leg for each repetition
and then bounce bounce bounce stretch
the leg forward and okay let's with
eight times weight on the left bounce
bounce bounce raise it here and down now
one bounce bounce bounce raise here and
down to weight on the left
bounce bounce bounce lift the heel and
down two on the right bounce bounce
bounce
lift the heel and down three on the left
bounce bounce bounce
leave the heel and down
film right bounce bounce bounce
leaf and forth on the Left bounce bounce
bounce
lift and down four on the right bounce
bounce bounce lift here and down five on
the left bounce bounce bounce lift the
heel down fighting the right bounce
bounce bounce lift the heel and up six
from the left bounce bounce bounce lift
the heel down six on the right bounce
bounce bounce
leave the heel and now seven on the left
bounce bounce bounce
leave the heel and down seven on the
right bounce bounce bounce lift the heel
and down
last one on the right bounce bounce
bounce on the Left sorry
leave the heel down my last one on the
right bounce bounce bounce
I leave the here and now if this is too
difficult to do without support you can
use a wall yeah you can put your hands
in the world and then hold it a bit
longer with the heel up okay so this was
the warm-up I hope you like it and let's
go to an
look where we are going to start to work
on our side step okay let's work on our
side step and we are going to start with
the beat it says that the big one so
we're going to see how the technique
works we will break the sidestep into
four basic movements and the movements
are as follows
we start in zero position and then the
first movement is to open your free leg
and at the same time bend your standing
leg like this just open the free leg and
bend the standing there the bell is so
that you can push the floor in the next
movement so the next movement will be
push the floor with a standing leg and
at the same time slide with your free
leg like this push and slide push and
slide the third movement will be the
actual transfer of weight from one leg
to the other okay so here you need to
coordinate your knees so that your
movement is parallel to the floor back
to the floor don't go down don't maja
don't tilt your torso don't do anything
with the hip just use your knees only on
your feet to transfer your weight
parallel to the floor and the fourth
movement is going to be just simply
close your free leg and return to the
upright position by stretching your
standing leg okay so let's go sweet
again first movement open your free leg
bend your standing leg like second
movement push with your standing leg and
slide with the free leg
third movement transfer your weight from
one leg to
and with fire to the floor and forth
movement close your free leg and stretch
your standing leg okay so it's going to
be one two three four one two three four
okay
now this exercise is for men and women
both if you're a woman you can do it
with your high heels if you have balance
problems all the exercises that we are
going to do in this class you can do
them by face in the world and putting
your hands on the world to support
yourself now if you need the world
I recommend don't put your whole hand on
the on the world because you need to be
able to move sideways and it's going to
be a bit awkward if your phone is on the
floor so just put the fingers put the
fingers and let them slide on the wall
okay
this is going to be better and if you're
a guy what I'm sorry I don't have any
excuse you you cannot use the wall you
have to be able to do this on your own
because you don't have packets okay so
we are going to do it as always with a
metronome a slow tempo of fifty eight
billion ladies and we are going to do
one basic movement of the side step on
each beat of the metronome so it's going
to be called slide change close open
slide change clothes one two three four
okay
let's get together sixteen times put
your weight on the right foot one two
three four one two three four one two
three four one two
see 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 a more 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 2 3
4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
ok great now we're going to do exactly
the same exercise but faster double as
fast so we will set an extensive
division on the metronome and then we're
going to do a movement on each beat of
the metal so it's going to be 1 2 3 4 1
2 3 4 open slide transfer close open
side transfer close okay like so let's
do it again 16 times put your weight on
the right foot let's go
one-two-three-four one-two-three-four
one-two-three-four two
one two three four one two three one two
three four one two three four one two
three four one two three four okay good
try to do it as big as you can yeah as
big as you can because in technique it's
about practicing the extremes even the
milonga later when you go dancing you
don't have space you can always reduce
it but it's good for training to be able
to do it big okay now in the next block
we're going to see how the technique
works for a small step okay let's see
now how our technique changes when we do
a small step so we started in zero
position like before and the first
difference is that on the first movement
when we open the free leg we are not
going to bend the standing leg the
standing leg will stay stretched so we
only open a little bit like this the
second difference is that obviously now
we don't need to push and slide like we
did before because this is only for
visitors
so for a small step after opening the
free leg we are going to go directly to
the transfer of weight from one leg to
another and you will see now that unlike
before now you don't need to use your
knees because your legs are already
straight okay and then after this second
movement we are going to just close the
free leg and return to zero position so
we only have three movements for a small
step opening the free leg without
bending the standing leg transferring
the
from one day to another with the legs
stretched and then just simply closing
the freely this is a small step now we
still want to fit it into the music into
four beats but you only have three
moments so the way we're going to do it
is that the last movement closing the
free leg is going to be twice as long
it's going to last two beats so we will
have open transfer close close open
transfer close close okay very slowly 1
2 3 1 2 3 3 3 3 you can't movements 3 4
if you come please ok so let's do it
again with a metronome without slow
tempo of 58 bpm and I know that this
movement is very very simple it might
feel a bit boring but you still have to
practice it ok so let's do it together
put your weight on the right foot and
let's start to blow open
[Music]
- okay great this was very easy if your
lady with high heels you should try to
be able to the beach without support of
the wall okay then so our is exactly the
same put your weight on the right foot
[Music]
- 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 ok
great
very good so this was the sidestep now
we are going to adapt this technique to
front steps and back steps ok now we are
going to adapt the technique that we use
for the beachside step to our front and
back step and it's going to be ladies so
I'm going to start here and I'm going to
have always my
my working leg towards the camera so you
can see what I'm doing
so let's about the four movements that
we'll have for the side step to the
front step so we start on zero position
and to my weight on the left and the
first movement was open the free leg and
then the standing leg so we're going to
open forward yeah and we're going to
bend the standing leg lightly so this is
a person be careful don't move back with
the doors when you're under keep the
chest forward the second movement is
push with the standing leg and slide
with the free leg so release push with a
standing leg and slide with a freely
play you can slide less or more if you
want a bigger step yeah
after this the third movement is
transfer your weight from one leg to the
and here like before coordinate your
knees so that your movement is parallel
to the floor that you don't go down or
up or that you don't bend the torso yeah
just use your meat so that you move
straight and parallel to the floor and
after needs the fourth movement is
simply close your free leg yeah after
closing we're going to change the weight
to the left hand so that the right leg
becomes free again and we can use it for
the back step so now let's see what they
need for the Buster which is the same
first we open the friggin to the bar
and we been missed
solution that is decent first movement
what the second ease push with a
standing leg and slide with the free leg
like this you can slide less or more for
a bigger step or a smaller step so push
and slide after this you're going to
transfer the weight from one leg
together again work with your knees so
let me move parallel to the floor
another is the fourth movement unless is
to just close your free leg bodies and
return to single position and change
weight so that the right leg is
available for the next front step okay
so let's go again sweet open the free
leg forward and push with a standing
then bend the standing leg push and snap
then transfer the weight and then close
the free leg
change weight open the free leg and then
the standing leg push one snipe then
transfer the weight and then close the
freeway okay so let's do it again with
the metronome slowly so 58 could be end
with one movement on each beat on the
Metro
so let's get to get sixteen times zero
position put your weight on the left
foot four
one two three four one two three four
one two three four and one two three
four a more open slide transferred close
open slide clansmen close open slide
transfer close open side three four one
two three four one two three four one
two three four okay now I have to get to
the other side so I'm going to stop here
and now the free day is going to be okay
so put your weight on the right 16 times
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 open slowly
transfer close open slide transfer close
open slide transfer comes open slide
transfer close anymore
one-two-three-four one-two-three-four
one-two-three-four one-two-three
[Music]
now 200
okay so I stand here feet together
wait on the right leg and we start with
it left front 16 times together 1 2 3 4
1 2 3 4 - 4
[Music]
one two three four okay very good in the
next book we will see how can we change
our technique for small steps back and
forth okay now we will adapt our
technique for short side steps to our
short steps front and back and it's
going to be like this if you remember we
only have three movements for short
steps the first one is to open your free
leg forward don't bend the standing leg
because we don't need to push the floor
for a big step
keep the standing leg straight after
opening the second movement is just to
transfer the weight from one foot to
another and here both legs are straight
you don't need to use the reins for this
after this comes the last movement the
third movement is to close the free leg
to return to zero position then we
change the way and we'll repeat this
backwards so first movement you open the
free leg keep your standing leg straight
second movement you transfer the weight
from one leg to the other and keep both
legs straight and the third movement
close your free leg to return to zero
position and change the weight so that
the right leg is available to start
again okay so we are going to do it an
end with a metronome
58 ppm with one movement for each beat
and remember that the last one is going
to be okay 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3
4 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 ok good now
let's new building side so I changed so
that my dream is always to the camera so
let's do it together 16 times 15 0
position and with your weight on the
right foot 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3
4 open - go
one two four one two three four one two
three four one two three four one two
three four okay
very good now we're going to repeat both
sides but this time with faster tempo so
dollar we set the next muscle
division on a metronome and now we are
going to go one movement on each beat of
the Metro so we are ready 16 cars
position on the left to open
[Music]
okay so this covers the technique for
all the basic directions for big and
small steps in the next book we're going
to start combining different directions
okay in this last book we're going to do
a small sequence where we will combine
front side back B and small steps okay
so that we start to experience in our
bodies how does it feel when we combine
all this technical ideas in a fluid
movement in a fluid sequence okay
so first I'm going to show you the
combination the structure of the
combination is very very simple
I start here because I need to move
forward now we are going to start in
zero position and we are going to do
three steps forward starting with the
left okay the first step is going to be
small and the next two
we'll be b and b then here we are going
to go up small side step to the right
and we will change the weight to the
left then we do the same thing going
backwards we do three steps going
backwards starting with the right leg
the first one is smaller and then the
next two are big big big and then here
we go are small size to the earth and we
change web surfing repeater here yeah so
remember small step with left piece that
with right big step with left small
sidestep with right change weight with
left small back step with right big back
step with left big back step with right
and then small size that with left
change we're good right okay that's the
structure now let's remember the
technique for each one of the steps yeah
so you start with the in zero position
with the weight on the right foot and
then first you open the left leg
transfer the weight and close the right
leg into it slowly then comes a big step
so you open the right leg and you bend
the left leg
because you want to go instead so you
open push and slide transfer great and
close now
now put another big step so you don't
need to change the right leg is already
been so just leave it there you do the
same thing again open push and slide
transfer and close now you stretch the
left leg the standing leg because the
sites that is small one so you open the
right leg transfer closed unchanged
now open the right leg back without
bending the left leg transfer the weight
with both legs straight and then close
in two weeks
close close now open the left leg and
bend the right leg open push and slide
transfer and close and then again the
same thing keep your left leg Bend and
then open push and slide transfer and
close and then you can stretch the right
leg because now comes a small side step
to the side so you just open transfer
the weight with the legs straight and
then close and change so that you can
start again with the left ok that's the
technique so let's do it together with a
metonym first as always with a slow
tempo of 58 ppm and afterwards we will
do it double as fast but now we will do
it very slowly so that in each step you
have
think all the technique of the stickers
are doing and I'm going to say each one
of their movements okay don't worry we
will do it eight times
okay so get ready fit in zero position
the weight is on the right foot and then
you start open transfer close close :
push on slide transfer close open ocean
side close open close
change colon cancer those drops open
ocean style the ransom close open ocean
side
close open and close cobra dancer goals
close all the bush and slide the answer
goes open ocean travel good answer
close open cancer growth change over
cancer close close open ocean side the
Lunsford close open ocean smell the
Lancer close open cancer jobs and change
color transfer close close open the
answer those open ocean side the answer
close open cancer those change :
close close open push and slide the
Lancer close open push and slide the
answer close open transmen
clothes change over dance goes
all emotions like their answer close
open push and slide the Lancer closed :
Colin change open dancer close close
open ocean side there are three cloves
open ocean sky dancer close company
dancer those change for more open
Johnson
clothes clothes Colbert Busch and staff
their answer close open push and slide
the answer goes köppen Johnson girls
change over transfer clothes clothes
open ocean side transferred clothes open
ocean side the Lancer closed :
transfer gross change over transfer
clothes clothes open push and solid
their answer clothes open ocean side
their arms close open
Johnson goes change open transfer close
close open ocean side there are three
close open push the slide the ransom
notes open transfer goes change quarter
drums
close close open push and Slavic the
Lancer close call push and slide their
answer
close open dancing clothes change
company transfer
close close open ocean side there are
three close call pushes
there are jokes open cancer closed
chains last one over transfer girls
girls
open push and slide the dance clothes
open push and side the answer close open
transfer clothes change open
transfer close close open push and slide
the transfer goes open push and slide
the Lancer closed colon cancer close
change
okay so now we will do the same but
we'll do it twice as fast
yeah so it's going to be one two three
four yeah instead of being open
transparent close is when we open
transfer close open slide transfer close
open slide transfer jobs open transfer
clubs yes okay so let's do it
fill in zero position weight on the
right foot and let's start 1 2 3 4 1 2 3
4 1 2 3 4 1 2
oh okay very well so that was it usually
I would try to make other combinations
for example you can try to change the
short side steps for big side steps so
that you can use the technique for a big
step also on the side step in
combination which will be all pollution
slide
transfer and close yeah I don't do it
now because I don't have space here if I
do it I'm gonna get out of the camera
and you wouldn't be able to see this
test but this is something you can do on
your own okay and as always repeat these
exercises as many times as you need to
try to challenge yourself with higher
temples or with sue over temples which
are also very challenging because you
really need a very good balance to dance
very slowly if you manage to use it to
do these exercises very slowly
then to do them faster will be no
problem at all so you will notice a very
good improvement of hydro-man in your
balance okay so I hope that you liked
this class today and I look forward to
see you on the next one thank you very
much